[موسيقى]
حبوب ذرة
أو
نحن لا نخلط بين الناس
الفرنسية والقادة الذين لديهم
الأجندة الأخرى الذين لديهم مشاريعهم التي
لا علاقة له بما يقولون
روما
لا بأسمائهم
عندما تدخل عام 2013
أنت ذاهب لتقسيم الكسافا هو أ
الملاذ الآمن
[موسيقى]
الى
م
[موسيقى]
نحن
تدخلت فرنسا في مالي
في المقام الأول للقتال
الإرهاب في المرتبة الثانية عند الطلب
لدولة ذات سيادة ودول
المنطقة هي هذا الشرط الثاني
أنهم كانوا يتغيرون وواجه النصر
للإرهاب ليس من الممكن إذا
لا تدعمه الدولة
نفسه
ولماذا قررنا اليوم
اترك بسبب
المجلس العسكري المسؤول عن
مالي لم تعد من أولوياته
[موسيقى]
سيطلق الأمريكيون في الفريق سراح
فرنسا
الجيش الأحمر ليس له جزء من
مكتب. مقر. مركز
بالرغم
عندما قرر الفرنسيون أنهم
لم تعد ضرورية للأمريكيين
الجزء هو ما حصل عليه الأمريكيون
بدأ في إهانة الفرنسيين